skincare mistake to stop doing number
one touching the dropper to your face
products are usually designed with the
packaging in mind responsible
formulators will put both jar and
dropper products through challenge
testing which is where the microbes are
added back into the product part way
through testing to check that the
product will still be safe if some
bacteria or mold lands in it dropper
bottles are usually considered lower
risk because they have a smaller opening
so they might have just enough
preservative added to pass challenge
testing
jars where you'd probably be dipping
your fingers into it every night might
have a high amount of preservatives to
deal with that extra risk on top of this
there are sometimes different past
levels for challenge testing and only
products that pass at the highest level
will end up in jars while products that
pass at a lower level might still end up
in less risky packaging like droppers so
if you're touching the dropper to your
face and then putting it back into the
bottle the dropper ends up right in the
middle of the product you're probably
making the preservative system do
something that it just wasn't meant to
do